hello everyone welcome to the second
video I'm making of a drawing for my
patreon drawing series last month I made
two drawings I made a drawing of Christ
the famous Christ I con from the Sinai
and I also made an image of Christ
enthroned from an early German ivory and
so this month I'm also going to start
with another version of Christ enthroned
but this time a Byzantine image it's
taken from one of the most famous
Byzantine ivories which is known as the
harborville triptych and so what I'm
hoping to do I'm trying to really look
into clothing and to see the differences
in clothing and the differences of
styles even looking at the German image
we can see that clothing is far more of
a pattern whereas in the Byzantine style
we can see how the clothing is more
flowing and has a more natural feeling
to it and so I really want to to dive
into that and see what the differences
are what the relationships are and so
hopefully that will be an interesting
thing to do all right
[Music]
so one of the interesting aspects of the
Byzantine image is of course the
position of Christ is quite different
from the the German one this to this
position the way that the Christ
Tolga goes around his arm and then under
the book is one which will continue to
exist until today though I would say
it's probably not the main image that's
used now for Christ and glory and it's
interesting to see how the Byzantines
even in the 10th and 11th century had
really preserved the the sense of the
Roman toga and understood clearly in a
physical way what was happening with the
clothing we're in as the German image
would make that interesting is there
seems to be a more of an effort to to
create these patterns of folds that go
down the figure and less of an effort to
work out exactly let's say physically
what the the clothing is doing and how
it's actually laying on the person and
so in a way that the visiting image is
more naturalistic and the German image
is more sure Attic and stylized I think
it's important I think at least for me
in the work that I'm doing in the carpet
that I'm doing I'm merely trying to get
the best of both of those the best of
the abstraction and the stylization
which is maybe more prominent in the
Romanesque and in the the northern the
northern images while preserving the
sense at least the best of what the
Byzantine and the Roman tradition had to
offer in terms of a play let's say of a
musical feeling flowing feeling in the
clothing and in the hair
one of the things I really struggle with
the ivories is the faces I really am not
prone to following the types of faces
that were used either by the Byzantines
or by the German so I tend to make my
use the clothing quite a bit because I
think the clothing is very well resolved
and well understood and interesting but
the the face I tend to resort to painted
icons and to see how to adapt the best
of the painted icons into a carving